have you ever tried a flaming hot Cheeto
Korean hot dog well if not you can visit
our friends at mochina Henderson who are
sponsoring today's segments Jillian
joins us live to show us uh some very
unique creations Jillian
hi Kendall and Mercedes yes you know I
already finished that Donut from earlier
but they have more than just donuts here
I'm with the founder of Mochi net we
have Matthew here with us Matthew thank
you so much for having us I appreciate
it so let's talk a little bit about it
you guys are celebrating one year
congratulations how does it feel you
made it to a huge milestone uh it feels
way less than a year it goes by very
quickly so but we're very happy to be
here still making donuts every day we do
a little bit of everything here we have
we have Mochi Donuts we have the Boba
and we have our really popular right
Korean style rice hot dogs they are very
similar to like a corn dog with their
lighter fluffier and they're kind of
crunchy in the outside so it's all about
the texture super fun and then we have a
lot of cool sauces as well so we do a
little bit of everything so you can come
here and get your salty your sweet you
can get all those Cravings all in one
yeah and in just a minute here you're
gonna show us one of your famous rice
hot dogs which I'm really excited to see
but you guys have a special promotion
going on too to celebrate the
anniversary tell us about that yeah you
come by uh anytime for the rest of the
day uh any purchase get to a free donut
so we're giving out free donuts all day
long and then also with if you come by
you mentioned Channel 8 news all through
the weekend as well through Sunday you
guys come on by mentioned you saw us on
Channel 8 and you guys get a free donut
as well so we are making extra Donuts
all week long for you guys to come on
down and try them oh my gosh well people
will be lining up the door to get that
and we have to wrap up here so I want to
call and see if that hot dog is ready
because you promised me you were going
to take a bite on air but it might be
too hot to eat so we can say that for
our next segment because we're going to
take bites of that you've got something
sweet coming up you guys have your milk
teas a little bit of everything so stay
tuned we will check back in with you
guys in a little bit here at mojina and
Henderson you don't want to miss it I'll
send it back to you guys in the studio